je compte jusqu'à 100000 oui quelqu'un
l'a fait j'écoute le réveil de l'iPhone
pendant 10h oui oui c'est SM je
transforme ma maison en aquarium géant
si ça a été fait quoi mais tout tu as
été fait c'est pas je kidnappe 20
personnes en 24 heures non non ça pas
été fait calmons-nous je me gifle
pendant 24 heures en une vidéo non si ça
a été et quoi je privatise la Maison
Blanche pour mes 30 ans non non je reste
24 heures dans un frigo oui
non pas mal je va prendre autre
vidéo qui qui est le plus fertile
concours what the fuck me non Logan Paul
je donne 10 million d'euros à un inconnu
dans la rue du mon beaucoup non non
j'offre une île privée à un abonné oui
Mister Beast je conduis un avion de
ligne sans aucune compétence oui non ah
non mais je pense en mode clickbait tu
vois j'ai payé un assassin pour tenter
de me tuer non je parcours toute la
Russie en pas chassé en pas attends mais
quoi le mec non
non